right now metro police are searching for
answers following a deadly shooting in
the southeast valley take a look here
police were called to monterey avenue
near flamingo and boulder highway last
night one person was killed another
injured this afternoon neighbors are
still shaken up
this neighbor who doesn't want to be
identified is very concerned she tells
me she didn't get much sleep after metro
police had her neighborhood blocked off
tuesday night around nine police were
called to the neighborhood for a
shooting they found an adult and a
two-year-old shot that adult died the
child shot in the leg is recovering
the woman recalls the chaotic scene with
police and ambulances even a helicopter
other neighbors telling me they heard
four gunshots moments before police
arrived they hope investigators can
quickly close this case and bring back a
sense of normalcy to their neighborhood
she says her entire family was scared
because they have two children everyone
gathered in the middle of the house and
away from any windows fearing the worst
throughout the night
well four males were taken into custody
last night according to metro police
they tell us all four are persons of
interest at this time and the victim has
not yet been identified